das grundproblem der raumfahrt ist in
einem satz zusammengefasst sie ist teuer
denn man benötigt große energien um die
nutzlast auf extrem hohe
geschwindigkeiten beschleunigen
ein professor aus den usa schlägt jetzt
eine lösung vor schwarze löcher könnten
als eine art licht schleuder dienen so
könnten raumschiffe extreme
geschwindigkeiten erreichen und somit
schnell und ohne großen
treibstoffverbrauch im alu mehr reisen
also der raum schiffsantrieb halo drive
jetzt den blick zum science fiction hier
gibt es täglich faszinierendes heinz
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
das ist eine ziemlich spannende
zukunftsvisionen von david kipping erst
astronom an der columbia university und
beschäftigt sich schon seit längerer
zeit mit schwarzen löchern in
zusammenhang mit der raumfahrt jetzt hat
er eine studie veröffentlicht in der er
beschreibt wie wir uns schwarze löcher
zunutze machen könnten um bei einer
reise durch das weltall energie und zeit
zu sparen kipping hält es für durchaus
möglich dass wir schon bald bemannte
reisen über weite distanzen im all
zurücklegen können doch dafür sei neben
neue technologien notwendig schwarze
löcher könnten uns dabei helfen quasi
als eine art beschleunigungs system im
weltraum fangen wir von vorne an und
zwar bei den sogenannten swing bei
manövern auf denen kippings idee
letztendlich passiert schon seit den
voyager raumsonden wird diese technik
genutzt dann mit raum besonnten quasi
kostenlos energie tanken können
die gravitationskraft der planeten wird
hier genutzt um raumsonden zu
beschleunigen oder auch abzubremsen denn
wenn die sonne als leichter körpernah an
einem vergleichsweise schweren
himmelskörper vorbeifliegt nimmt sie
quasi energie von ihm auf so kann nicht
nur geschwindigkeit sondern auch die
flugrichtung geändert werden wenn die
raumsonde sich wieder entfernt bremst
der planet see ab das ist alles eine
frage der perspektive aus sicht des
planeten verlässt die raumsonde ihn mit
derselben geschwindigkeit wie sie sich
ihm genähert hat eben nur in eine andere
richtung aus sicht der sonne sieht das
alles ganz anders aus so gesehen kommt
zu der geschwindigkeit der raumsonde die
geschwindigkeit des planeten hin zu
relativ zur sonne gesehen ist sie also
effektiv schneller geworden der planet
selbst wird durch die ganze sache
nur einen minimalen dicke langsamer doch
durch seine gigantische masse im
vergleich zur raumsonde ist dies zu
vernachlässigen niemand kann seinen
geschwindigkeitsverlust überhaupt messen
doch die fähigkeiten dieser swing by
schleuder die sind begrenzt denn mit der
technik dieses manövers lässt sich die
geschwindigkeit maximal um die doppelte
geschwindigkeit des planeten erhöhen
der merkur beispielsweise bewegt sich
auf seiner bahn im sonnensystem mit
einer geschwindigkeit von 47 4
kilometern pro sekunde für eine
interstellare reise aber braucht man
eben deutlich mehr geschwindigkeit
nämlich zumindest relevante bruchteile
der lichtgeschwindigkeit die ja bei
knapp 300.000 kilometern pro sekunde
liegt in der theorie gibt es ideen um
dieses manöver effektiv zu gestalten und
zwar mit hilfe eines engen doppel
neutronensterns der us-physiker freeman
dyson hatte 1963 bereits zwei
neutronensterne vorgeschlagen die
jeweils etwa eine sonnenmasse aufweisen
und sich alle fünf millisekunden einmal
umkreisen ein raumschiff könnte durch
einen engen vorbeiflug auf bis zu 81
tausend kilometer pro sekunde
beschleunigt werden das entspricht 27
prozent der lichtgeschwindigkeit doch
diese überlegung enthält einen fatale
nachteil die gezeitenkräfte des doppel
neutronensterns sind gigantisch und
würden das raum spaghetti feeds ihren
dieser begriff wurde von stephen hawking
geprägt und meint die verformung von
objekten wenn diese in die nähe eines
schwarzen lochs geraten es wird zunächst
in die länge gezogen und dann
auseinandergerissen bildlich gesehen
eben wie die form von spaghetti doch
klar ist auch nicht nur schwarze löcher
sind in der lage objekte zu
spezifizieren sondern eben auch doppel
neutronensterne und damit kommen wir
zurück zu dem astronomen david kipping
und seiner aktuellen arbeit denn er hat
sich eine möglichkeit überlegt wie eine
bemannte reise im weltall mit hilfe von
schwarzen löchern noch schneller werden
könnte und dass eben ohne das risiko
einzugehen am ende als spaghetti zu
enden konkret schlägt kipping vor
schwarze löcher als spiegel zu nutzen
dass sie objekte wie eine art spiegel
wirken das weiß man schon seit 1993
kipping müsse leserlich sehr gezielt an
dem schwarzen loch vorbei gelenkt werden
um das schwarze loch herum befindet sich
das sogenannte photonen halo ist eine
zone in der das licht das schwarze loch
ein oder mehrmals umkreis das licht das
dem schwarzen loch ziemlich nahe kommt
bleibt zunächst in diesem photonen helau
außerhalb dieses bestimmten radius
amaras das licht vorbei wird in die
gegenrichtung umgelenkt und kommt so wie
ein bumerang zurück mit einem licht
segel könnte das raum schrift die
photonen dann wieder auffahren
vereinfacht gesagt wird also der effekt
dass schwarze löcher wie ein spiegel
wirkung und photonen wieder zu ihrer
ursprungsquelle zurück schleudern
ausgenutzt skipping nennt diese
ultimative schleuder halo 3 schiffe
schießen also laserstrahlen in richtung
des schwarzen lochs und die photonen die
zurückkehren werden mit einem segel
wieder eingefangen so kann an
geschwindigkeit zugelegt werden ohne
dass viel energie benötigt wird das
ganze berechnet kipping auch mit hilfe
von komplizierten formeln letztendlich
kommt er zu dem ergebnis dass so eine
endgeschwindigkeit erreicht werden
könnte die bank 133 der geschwindigkeit
des schwarzen lochs liegt in kippings
vision könnte die raumfahrt in zukunft
die rund zehn millionen schwarzen löcher
die es schätzungen zufolge in der
milchstraße gibt als eine art express
autobahn system nutzen quer durch die
galaxie reisen auf riesigen netzwerken
von interstellaren autobahn und sich so
von einer station zur nächsten schießen
lassen wow was für ein ärger aber
gleichzeitig auch geniale gedanke
kipping schreibt auch dass ein
raumschiff nicht unbedingt selbst seine
eigene laserlicht welle mitbringen muss
ein entsprechender laser könnte
stattdessen auch auf einen planeten
installiert werden
zudem könnten statt licht auch
teilchenstrahlen also eine art ionen
antrieb genutzt werden schaut man sich
die relativitätstheorie genauer an wird
klar dass es theoretisch gesehen
tatsächlich möglich ist bruchteile der
lichtgeschwindigkeit zu erreichen
der von kipping beschriebene halo 3
sorgt dafür dass mehr photonen energie
zurück bleibt als anfangs aufgewendet
wurde
in der theorie könnten somit also ganze
planeten massen in bewegung versetzt
werden offen lässt bringt er noch eine
wichtige frage wie können wir ein
geeignetes schwarzes loch in
angemessener zeit erreichen kipping hat
angekündigt sich mit diesem aspekt in
seinen noch folgenden arbeiten zu
beschäftigen denn wenn dieses problem
nicht gelöst
wird bleibt die idee reine theorie
schwarze löcher erklärt cooles video
unbedingt draufklicken anschauen und
vikings abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran